[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor of the liverpool echo liam thorpe
and the assistant comment editor of the
telegraph olivia utley welcome to both
of you with us i know right through
until just before midnight
front pages let's start with those shall
we the front page of the metro featuring
the news that british man scott sibley
has been killed in ukraine
the financial times leads on joe biden's
plea to the u.s congress to approve 33
billion dollars in extra aid for ukraine
and the u.s president's plans to
increase aid also featuring on the front
page of the guardian
the telegraph features the news that
britain is to send 8 000 troops to
eastern europe in one of the largest
deployments since the cold war
new sexual harassment claims hit
parliament that's the headline on the
front of the eye as westminster is
rocked by a series of scandals
the daily mirror has an exclusive on its
front page james bulger's murder is to
be debated in parliament raising hopes
of a public inquiry nearly 30 years on
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch the program so let's bring in liam
thorpe and olivia utley who join us now
and liam let's start with the the metro
and those other newspapers uh that have
um led on the news that uh that a
british man has been killed in ukraine
another as we know is missing many of
the newspapers carrying a picture of
scott sibley this 36 year old who is uh
the first known uk casualty of this
nine-week conflict
absolutely uh it's it's extremely sad um
not surprised to see um newspapers
putting this story on the front page
because obviously it really brings it
home here to to people in the uk as well
this is scott siblia he's a father of
two as you said believed to be 36 and it
is the first known uh uk casualty of of
what is now an increasingly long and and
devastating conflict um as well as the
the tragic death of mr sibley we
understand that uh
another uk national is is missing and
and the families of both are being
supported uh it says in the metro piece
that mr sibley has a young daughter who
was was suffering with a rare cancer as
well so it's a another sort of tragedy
for for that family he was part of a
special unit that had gone out to
to help with the ukrainian effort to
push back from this russian invasion
um and he obviously had a huge sense of
duty as an ex-serviceman he just wanted
to go out there and and help ukraine
defend itself um he's there's some
really moving quotes from people who
served with him when he was in the army
saying he was a beautiful guy inside and
out stood up for them was always there
for them and you know people can't
believe he's gone i think even even
though he was obviously willing to put
himself in in the firing line it's still
a massive massive shock to
his friends and family and an absolutely
tragic lawson and it just reminds
everyone of what is happening over there
you know sometimes
a long and
difficult conflict like this goes
slightly down the news agenda and then
something like this just brings it
straight back up again and we were
reminded about the absolute horrors of
war
yes and a fundraising page set up in mr
sibley's name pay tribute to his
contagious laugh and ability to to cheer
us all up um you know no doubt his
family are absolutely reeling uh about
this uh and you know a very very
difficult war to fight as we know from
the pictures we've seen you know across
this conflict and there's some confusion
about how the government felt about
british nationals going out to fight in
ukraine at the start of all of this we
cast our minds back to
the end of february when liz trusts the
foreign secretary said she absolutely
supported uk nationals who chose to
fight for ukraine which you know went
down very badly um
by russia among amongst other people
olivia
yeah i mean i think liz trusts words
that there was some confusion over what
she said uh what she meant was was
veterans like mr sibley with training in
the armed forces uh mike might feel that
that they could go and help in ukraine
um but there was some misunderstanding
and there were some people who thought
you know any old person um off the
street should just wander in and and go
to the front line which probably
wouldn't be particularly helpful so we
had ben wallace back then rowing back a
little bit on what liz trust said um it
definitely very much anger putin angered
russia um we heard someone you know
talking about the british foreign
secretary wouldn't say her name but but
it definitely riled up putin and i think
that was
perhaps the start of when it became very
clear that britain was going to be a
pretty strong leader in europe um
against russia in this war um and now
and now we've seen the first british
casualty well liz trust obviously gave
her mansion house speech last night uh
where she talked about the need to
double down on help for ukraine today
joe biden the ft leading on this um with
this enormous contribution now asking
congress for 33 billion dollars in
military economic and humanitarian aid
to support ukraine and certainly in the
last week um there's been a there's been
a shift in focus isn't there um liam in
terms of you know what needs to be done
by western allies uh and the
contributions they're willing to make
now towards ukraine
yeah this is hugely significant
everybody knows that the us is the is
the the major ally that ukraine feels it
needs on its side and this is a
joe biden asking for asking congress to
approve 33 billion dollars worth of
support and that is double what they
have previously approved this is
for a whole host of things
main you know large amounts of artillery
and weaponry economic support
shared intelligence it's a it's a big
moment really and it's a significant
step particularly as it comes almost
directly after the kremlin warned about
sort of retaliation for anyone offering
further support to ukraine so it's a
it's a marker from the us it's a it's a
line in the sand obviously
they're not they don't want to take that
step of entering ukraine they don't want
to to sort of have boots on the ground
there but it's it's getting to the point
where it's as as close to that without
actually going in in terms of the
support that's being offered um and and
i think the other thing that it shows we
heard liz trust saying in her speech you
know how long this walk would go on for
um this this is the us showing that they
too believe that this is going to be a
long a long conflict i mean this that's
a huge amount of money and it's
suspected that will only really last
until perhaps september i think most
people would believe it's going to go on
from there but part of that because
ukraine has shown such remarkable
resistance but obviously that russia now
focusing heavily on the on the donbass
region and i think the u.s and other
areas are worried about russia making
significant gains there hence this this
uh stepping up of the support being
offered
and certainly the guardian picks up on
that idea that uh joe biden is defying
the threats that we saw this week from
president putin um with this 33 billion
dollar package of aid and uh pointing
out as well that just a few hours after
joe biden had spoken during this visit
to kiev by the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres the city was shaken by
two cruise missile strikes certainly
seen by some as a warning of yet another
visit by a a global leader to keeve
which you know you know russia keeps
retaliating against um but this all
began really didn't it at the weekend
when more than 40 nations met to
increase weapons aid to kiev um you know
and they really are now putting their
hands in their pockets over this one it
seems olivia
yes stephanie and it's amazing to see
how much uh joe biden's line has has
shifted since the start of this war and
you know we remember just a few months
ago when he was implying that the us
might not like turn a blind eye but but
but not really act too strongly to a
minor incursion is how he put it and now
he's he's really walking the walk um and
it does show as liam says that that the
americans think that this war is going
to go on the brits think this war is
going to keep going and they're leveling
up for the next stage of this conflict
um i think it's also a suggestion you
know that biden also believes that that
russia could possibly be defeated and
it's definitely true that um that both
britain both liz russia in her speech
and biden now uh is calling putin's
bluff on the on the nuclear weapons um
and i think there's stuff that i've you
know been speaking to some experts
who've you've said that uh there there
is some there is a school of thought
that the russian army is really really
flagging now and doesn't have that much
left in it so it feels like there's one
huge push um and and and something can
be done so it does feel like just uh the
next phase that we're entering um at the
end of this week yes certainly we're
reminded of the u.s defense secretary's
words are trying to weaken russia so
they you know can't do this again
effectively uh interesting front page in
the daily telegraph liam uh britain sent
8 000 troops to eastern europe
uh with exercises to deter russia
announced as well um this is uh this is
the largest they say deployment since
the cold war fascinating
yeah very interesting we're just talking
about
you know the us kind of stepping up its
response and this is certainly uh
britain
doing the same
in a kind of very symbolic move i i
would say and and these these 8 000
troops obviously you know a small amount
compared to i guess what's going on in
ukraine but it as i say it's quite
symbolic moving they're going to be
sort of stretched across eastern
european countries it says from north
macedonia to finland which is very
interesting because we know that finland
are weighing up an application to join
nato it does feel whether it's the us or
the uk that this is not just this is not
just about ukraine it's about showing a
sort of symbolic nato front or a front
with allies in terms of you know
the countries nearby as well because
they're obviously very worried we've
seen that from finland and sweden and
other countries in that area which are
now
now being brought almost brought into
this idea of joining nato because of
what russia has done so this is britain
just i think with a bit of it i think
ben wallace described it as a show of
strength and solidarity to those
countries around ukraine as well as
offering support to ukraine as well
and let's move on to uh the metro shall
we um olivia as well this is the un
secretary general who you know
poignantly said that as he was shown
some of the horrors near kiev i imagine
my family um you know dying in these
ruins my grandchildren he talked about
um you know once again somebody has seen
for themselves the damage that's being
done in this war
yes and and seeing these world leaders
come into kiev um coming into other
parts of ukraine uh when it's still
extremely dangerous does show just that
how strong that show of support is and
just how much things have changed over
the last you know three months since
this conflict began and right at the
start of the war it did feel as though
europe couldn't quite get its act
together there was no clear line there
was uh macron doing his own sort of
diplomacy uh on the side and then uh
germany not not quite uh committing to
support ukraine because obviously if
it's gas dependency on on russia britain
doing something else entirely um and now
it feels like all of those leaders have
come together with biden as well um very
much under the umbrella for you n and
you've got and you've got andrew anthony
guerras gushrez uh in keith sort of
showing that symbol of solidarity and it
does feel like everyone's united now
under this one umbrella and and is ready
as ready as they can possibly be for for
this next phase and ready for the idea
of a much longer war and not just uh
guerrilla warfare in the cities but but
a long drawn-out strategic
war and and and i think these these
poignant speeches from leaders in
ukraine
it does it it brings it back to us back
home and you know watching boris in
ukraine uh you you felt you know proud
that we're doing something to help and i
think that's what people all around un
countries will be feeling today
and this idea that um you know the west
now believes ukraine can win um just
going back to the the telegraph uh
russian authorities in hassan said that
they would be switching the region's
payments to the ruble in the biggest
indication today the moscow intends to
extend jurisdiction to parts of ukraine
uh we remember when they took away the
local mayor didn't they uh
in places like military and everything
so that that's already begun and people
are talking about an off-ramp for putin
but he's still saying and this week has
reiterated
that all aims will be achieved with the
idea of still you know taking the
donbass and and this land bridge to
crimea so people should still be very
nervous about this war and how long it
will go on for liam
absolutely you know
i understand people
everyone is desperate for this to end
and desperate for the the horrors to end
and people are reaching for for
solutions and a lot of that you know
they want to try and imagine a world
where where putin would negotiate or in
some way climb down from from his own
aims but there's no evidence of that
there's no evidence remember at the
start of the war when
it was all about ukraine not joining
nato and zolensky was
you know was prepared to talk about that
but these things go out the window as
putin just continues with this horrific
assault so it's hard to really imagine a
world or a scenario where he's going to
get around the negotiating table and and
give a little and take a look just he's
not acting like that he's not acting
like a a reasonable person in in any
shape or form so yeah it's hard to
imagine and obviously the the
calculation from the west whether people
agree with it or not is that that's not
going to happen and the and the only way
is
for putin to stop is either to be
defeated or to to achieve his aims and
they're obviously going on the side of
him being defeated
liam olivia stay there both of you
plenty more still to come including new
sexual harassment claims hitting
parliament we will be discussing that
after the break
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the political
editor of the liverpool echo liam thorpe
and the assistant comment editor of the
telegraph olivia artley welcome back to
both of you uh olivia settling her shot
as we can see um let's talk about the
the somewhat torrid week in parliament
going to the eye shall we
hello olivia sorry hello uh yes it's
been a extremely bad week for for
westminster um it always seems to be
another bad week for westminster we've
got a collection of female mps now from
all sides of the house coming together
to talk about the uh misogyny they've
experienced in the in the wake of the
angela rayna story in the wake of the mp
who has been uh who who was caught
watching pawn on his phone in the house
of commons uh still not clear who that
is a tory mp but it's very clear as it
has been for a while now that that
westminster's this kind of bed of of
a tinderbox basically um and and now
we've got this group of women coming
together to talk about their experiences
uh and just sort of shine a light on it
again um we had this a few years ago
with the with the pessimistic scandal
nothing really seemed to change um but
it does feel as though you know in the
wake of me too that there might be a
growing move to to to sort of clean up
westminster a little bit this idea of
having sort of young staffers around mps
in the corridors of power drinking after
hours etc just doesn't seem to be
particularly conducive to a good working
environment and i think you know having
these women talking about that is
probably a good thing for westminster
well quick one on working environments
of a different kind uh this is the daily
telegraph going back to the story of the
head of the passport office after it was
revealed they'd been working from home
and leicestershire a hundred miles away
from her organization's hq
but getting the backing of the permanent
secretary at the home office who said
that where the passport office's
director-general worked had precisely
zero bearing on the crisis engulfing her
organization um tell us more liam
yeah it seems to be becoming a real kind
of uh political sort of hot potato this
we saw um what i believe was a pretty um
crude really um act by jacob rees-mogg
when he when he or or people working for
him left these these leaflets on civil
servants desks sort of passive
aggressive notes uh saying you know you
basically you should be back in the
office um and this is um you know
matthew rycroft who's the permanent
secretary at the home office has
has basically come out fighting for
those wanting to still work from home
and saying that the current issues with
the backlogs at the passport offices it
has is nothing to do with civil servants
working from home it it's becoming a
real issue in in westminster this and
the conservative government clearly are
very very pro
i don't mean to cut in i've got the
weather forecast to get him i do
apologize liam thought love it up thank
you both very much indeed thank you